hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled 2020 food and beverage
regulatory trends impact and next steps
i'm susie valdez elaborates and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by milliporesigma
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you'd like during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located
at the far left of your screen i now
present
today's speaker justice delica
food and beverage regulatory liaison at
millipora stigma
she is responsible for engaging with
influencers in the food and beverage
industry to align initiatives
to be the highest regulatory compliant
and promote best practices among
testing methods promoting the safest and
highest quality foods
for complete biography on justice please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
welcome justice you may now begin your
presentation
hello welcome everyone i'm so
very excited you're all here today and
so excited to uh discuss with you
our 2020 regulatory trends impact and
next steps
today's discussion will revolve mostly
around
the united states regulations and what's
going on
um and specific to the food and beverage
industry
so we have a lot of information to get
through today
and um so let's just jump in and get it
going
so before we get started um just a
reminder for everyone a little legalese
if you will
that the life science business of merck
kgaa darmstadt germany
operates as milipor sigma in the us and
canada
so those of you outside us and canada
totally familiar with uh
says mark kga a darmstadt germany and
those in the us
you're more familiar with millipore
sigma but together
we've all worked together in the same
great company
so today just to kind of get rolling um
we have a lot to go through 2020 has
been a
crazy year in regards to regulations
uh so many key factors four major
buckets that i kind of came up with
uh to really organize and kind of think
through what is
influencing our regulations um from a
global perspective we have the gfsi the
global food safety
initiative and i'm not sure if you guys
have heard of this yet but
evidently there's this pandemic 19 going
on
had a tremendous impact on the food
industry
so we'll talk a lot about that um
but life still goes on outside pandemics
so we're going to need to talk a little
bit about some fisma
updates occurring this year and finally
we're going to finish it up with the
most
important influencer of all you
all of us working in the food industry
and
also consumers of food um what we think
what we feel
about our food and how it's regulated
and managed
is the most important opinion and just
to kind of
touch on some areas where we help
influence
what's going on this year
so with that uh let's start off with the
gfsi
so early this february i was so very
fortunate and grateful
to be able to attend the gfsi conference
in seattle washington what a tremendous
inspiration being around
so many different food safety leaders
with the sole goal of making food safe
and high quality for everyone everywhere
such an inspiration four key topics were
really discussed throughout the
conference
uh definitely certification version 2020
tremendous resonance around food safety
culture
as well as hygienic design and top of
everyone's minds and still very relevant
even today
is the idea of supply chain transparency
and what this means from day to day
so because we have so many things to get
through in this presentation
i'm just going to hit on a couple
highlights
on the gfsi certification 2020.
so this really was a roadmap to really
help and enhance
and align all of the different uh
certification
[Music]
throughout the globe um to really make
one structure that
seemed to make sense and was the best
path forward for food safety
um some of the key elements were in
alignment and harmonization
and simplification of the language and
alignment with iso 22000
as well as the codex
and some new elements that were really
exciting
and we're going to touch on specifically
were the idea
of a food safety culture as well as
hygienic design
and just a really enhancement and
further definition
of everything else that was in that
certification um
in previous versions uh just really kind
of
further honing in and just like
buttoning up to make sure that they are
the best
aligned regulations possible the gfsi
website
has tremendous wealth of resources um as
well as guides
and implementation strategies available
for your
use that you can work with your
accreditation body to make sure that
your certification
is up to date ready to roll
so the most important topic that really
has been hitting
our industry globally but definitely
as well in the united states is this
idea of a food safety culture
so interesting what does it mean when we
say
food safety culture seems to mean
something different for
everyone i found this world word cloud
on uh food online and
for me it really talks about a lot of
the things that come to mind
on food safety so as you
think about it food safety culture are a
lot of the ideas you're thinking
um listed on this word cloud what else
is missing
so i investigated um i found a couple
definitions that really kind of
resonated for me
so one of which was put forth by safe
food alliance and they defined food
safety culture
as a specific culture of a facility
the attitudes benefits practices and
values
that determine what is happening when no
one is
watching so for me that means
that it's one thing to do what you're
told when you're told to do it
and check in that box and you're good to
go but
really that idea of culture really
culminates
when what do you do when no one's paying
attention
is this something that's truly part of
your culture
the fda really aligns with this as well
frankianes in his new era
of smarter food safety postulates
that strengthening food safety cultures
also
extends to the home and fda is working
to educate consumers
on safe food handling practices
so for me the key takeaway here
is not that this is happening just at
work
um and how are you promoting this at
work to meet specific regulations
but are you taking this home are you a
true fake food safety hero
a food safety leader you know as you're
teaching best practices to your family
to your friends how are you promoting
this idea of
food safety culture throughout um
and then to cap it off the gfsi
also has a definition of food safety
culture
and they define it as shared values
beliefs and norms that affect mindset
and behavior
towards food safety in and throughout
an organization so really how does this
blend and marinate together to really
create this rich culture
of food safety but at the end of the day
these are what these organizations feel
what's most important is how you feel
when you go to work as a food safety
professional
you know is food safety culture at top
of your mind
do you feel empowered to
speak up when you feel that an
improvement can be
made um is the
consistency of how food safety culture
rolled out
consistently across your organization is
the ceo
or your lab technician or your line
worker is it a consistent and constant
of you and vision of food safety all of
these wrapped up together
culminate that food safety culture so
at the end of the day lots of
definitions available
but what matters most is how this
impacts
you
and one of the most important elements
in a food
safety culture is really this idea of
hygienic
design so much
important was the gfsi created a
technical working group to tackle this
very
issue at the end of the day their
conclusions
were really as basic as it needs to be
the right equipment
and easy to clean so what they thought
after a tremendous review was to align
with the european hygienic
engineering and design group
they have published uh very specific
guidelines on what it means to have
hygienic design
um and very specific uh requirements
but basically at the end of the day the
most important topics
and pieces of it are basically
is it clean and can you clean it
and does it prevent microorganisms
pests and contamination if you can meet
these you've got a pretty good hygienic
design
and it also needs to be compatible with
any other things
that are going on in your processes now
obviously that's a tremendous
oversimplification
of what hygienic design is but
um as long as you're eliminating those
little nooks and crannies and your
processes and your equipment
that allow all of these
offenders to contaminate your workplace
uh you're pretty good so i encourage you
to download the regulations
and i have some resources here available
to you to kind of
decide you know are you achieving
hygienic design
in your processes
the last topic of tremendous discussion
at gfsi this year was supply chain
transparency
frank giannis spoke and rolled out his
era of food
of smarter food safety in it
uh he really talked about um not just
doing more
but doing the right things so being
smart about decisions that are being
made
and one such element was really
leveraging and utilizing
new digital technologies um such as
blockchain
came up everywhere um
amazon gave an amazing uh talk as well
on how they utilize blockchain and
digital technologies to really drive
their supply chain
uh it really does seem that people
want things when they need them and they
need to have the information available
the right information when they need it
um that this is no longer a nice to have
it's kind of the acceptable norm
so um and it's only going to increase
from there
and then finally at the end of the day
really again
consumer demand um no longer is it
acceptable
uh to moms and dads everywhere to kind
of see
that oh cool this is an avocado from
guatemala cool
this is an avocado from texas um
they have special feelings about what
that means maybe the avocado from
guatemala is a special taste
and the avocado from texas might be
a different characteristic um for some
reason that holds
a certain value for some individuals
they want to know where their food is
from and where it's been along its
journey to their dinner table
so they want to be able to be at the
grocery store and
a click and a check be able to see
exactly
where their food is if you'd like a
demonstration
of a little glimpse into how this works
i would encourage you
to visit our lenexo a booth in the
exhibit hall
they have an amazing demonstration on
how
use of rfid technology can really
uh hone in and increase your efficiency
and uh in your labs and just
think if we can do this in labs what
does this look like for the entire food
chain
for everyone everywhere
so as gfsi was happening
um in seattle everyone was notified
covid made it to the us and
the world literally closed um
but it's still important uh to mention
uh so much of the work that's going on
that really affects
and helps our industry so i'm going to
touch on some of the government
uh updates and the work that's gone
forth uh
talk specifically about one specific
industry that's
really been affected and then talk about
going into the future and the increased
need for
environmental monitoring and
sanitization
so how many of you
went to the grocery store for the very
very very first time in march
to bare shelves like where did
everything go
literally overnight everything was gone
so many questions what happened
still waiting to find out where the
toilet paper went crazy and i'm
sure we're all bored of the joke but but
seriously
um people were scared they didn't know
what to do
and the things that they were used to
having were gone
so what do we do about it
well the fda and usda quickly went to
work
this is just a snapshot into some of
the policies and
that they put forth just keep the
industry going and moving forward
we couldn't let people starve food
needed to be available
and we couldn't let our businesses fail
so with all of the great
tremendous support of the fda and usda
uh
we were able to keep the industry moving
some of the most
notable pieces as you can see were
an immediate uh relaxation
on a couple policies to kind of let the
industry focus
specifically um on some of the on-site
audits
uh a relaxation on that uh for this year
uh this was done in part to keep workers
safe at
fda and usda then also allow the
businesses to be able to focus on their
business
implement new uh strategies
to protect both workers and food safety
and you can see this through some of the
labeling policy changes
to where they allow restaurants to sell
bulk food directly to consumers with
relaxed packaging and labeling
considerations
as well as the most recent with some of
the nutritional
label relaxation in regards to
vending machines but a tremendous amount
of work
um i would encourage you to look on the
fda usb website
just just get a glimpse of everything
that's been going on
it's amazing so much could get done in
such a short amount of time
but they're not the only ones who've
been busy the government has been busy
as well
um we've had two executive orders
uh signed in recent months to protect
the food chain
specific in regards to the food uh
was the dpa for the food supply chain
um which really impacted the meat
industry which we'll talk about in a
second
but um measures were being taken to make
sure
that the food industry didn't fail
congress also passed uh quickly
legislation such as the pay check
protection program
family's first coronavirus response act
in the corona bios
preparedness and response supplemental
appropriations act
all of these combined provided resources
and support for the food industry
and food industry companies to make sure
that workers were protected
businesses were protected and our supply
chain kept on moving
um but they didn't stop there every day
there's more and more
bills um being submitted for
consideration i list just a few here
that are under consideration of most
impact
or you might be most familiar with is
the heroes act
and then the amendment to the
agriculture marketing act
and then farmers feeding families act um
those have been getting specific
attention in recent months
and um we'll have to watch to see uh
how those end up affecting the industry
so because of the executive order and
some challenges
um and business in general um i call
this the battle of the means
um so in mid to late march
uh employee after employee at meat
processing
facilities began testing positive for
covid and unfortunately
resulted in deaths it was
a tremendous setback for the industry
in a very unsettling time
facilities needed to close um to stop
and uh deal with the setbacks
they had to work with they worked very
closely with osha cdc
fda usda to really figure out
um the best path forward and keep the
supply chain going
especially after the signature of the
executive order
um progress has been made plans have
started opening
new practices implemented and changes
and procedures
so again the meat industry is on its way
back up
and it looks to be uh
they're making up business uh last i
read they were up to
90 in capacity which is very hopeful for
the future
conversely um the alternative
meat industry seized on an opportunity
earlier this year they were under uh
scrutiny
on um labeling and marketing claims
uh there was lots of debate on
should they or should they not be
considered a meat
and what did it mean to be a meat but a
lot of that was thrown
out the door as soon as uh coveted hit
because there was a gap in the supply
chain and
consumers like the taste of meat
and burgers are part of an american
tradition whether it's made out of
a it's a traditional burger or if it's
uh
plant-based so definitely an opportunity
and then at the end of may we could see
that sales of
meat alternative products were soaring
to all record highs
so the future um for me
looks like meat non-meat or meat
alternative whatever
you're choosing it's ready to go for you
and readily available
but at the end of the day everything
needs to be kept safe
we need to make sure that our food is
safe
um and then we also need to make sure
that our workers are safe
so as far as keeping the environment
clean
and safe um the epa
put out guidance for a list of approved
disinfectants against
covid with the caveat to remember
that the sanitizers that you use need to
be approved and recommended for food
manufacturing
use still need to be safe
the fda's guidance was that increased
sanitization and frequency of cleaning
would need to be implemented
and just as a reminder that anytime
changes are made in your processes
or your risk level changes in your
manufacturing process
these need to be documented and included
in your hassle plans
so the other element not just your
processes is keeping workers
safe so osha put out guidance on
how to create an infectious disease
preparedness and response
plan it's very detailed on
mentioning steps what to do if a worker
gets sick
how do you protect other workers if
someone's sick does that make it an
unsafe working environment and just how
do you mitigate that risk
and organize your workplace so that
everybody is safe
and healthy and feels comfortable and
safe coming to work
um so been working very very hard to
make sure that everyone is protected
um and that we get through this pandemic
safe secure and well fed
but at the end life will still go on
and we still have deadlines to make so
there's a couple things that have been
implemented and are set to hit the books
this year
for the food safety and modernization
act
um some uh elements dealing with imports
um intentional adulteration and then the
lab accreditation program
so just uh very briefly just some things
um just just dates um that are occurring
but
to be mindful of the very last element
of the foreign supplier verification
program
uh finally hits uh this year in july
27th
uh very small businesses will now be
required to comply with this piece of
the regulation
and this really is the last piece um
that completes the foreign supplier
verification program
the last two pieces that were
implemented last year
will now be part of the program for this
year so
i'm just extending that compliance date
for
food contact substances as well as for
cotton jenning facilities
those are ready to roll and fully
implemented for this year
the final piece is the voluntary
qualified
importer program they have
extended the application deadline to
july 31st
this is mostly due because of the coven
pandemic
it was very challenging for
accreditation bodies to go
and visit and conduct on-site audits
internationally to really verify
that these importers are safe and in
compliance
therefore the deadline has been extended
at the july 31st
date the portal will close for review
and then benefits will start rolling out
in october of this year
one topic of specific
um evolution
is the lab accreditation program this
was an element
that was included as part of fisma that
um stated that labs um that
were for final release testing of food
products needed to be an accredited lab
by an accreditation body however
it was never established what did it
mean to be
an accreditation body and what does an
accredited lab
mean exactly so the fda put out for
public comments
um those comments are still open until
july 6th
to find out what's already in place how
does the industry feel about this what
does the industry want
need um just really capturing feedback
um what the fda would like to do is
propose
a framework and requirements for what
does it mean to be an accreditation body
and also what are the steps um and
requirements needed for
labs that are looking to be accredited
now what is nice that is occurring is
that they don't want to reinvent the
wheel they want to
work with programs and policies and
practices that are already in place
so that what is established is both
familiar and comfortable
and doesn't inhibit business so they
really are
incorporating all of the comments to
really create the best program
possible without starting over
at the end of the day though they still
would like to be focused on three major
pieces
they want to make sure that they are
always informed on the testing results
on what is going on
they want to maintain oversight of the
program
and then finally they will still want
the ability to be able to conduct audits
and investigations
as needed so more will be coming in the
next couple months
um on this topic and hopefully we'll get
some new
uh guidance and regulations in the
later coming months of this year
final topic with fisma that really hits
um home for a lot of us is this
intentional adulteration
uh i know last year there was a lot of
press
on adulterated olive oil
or counterfeit olive oil actually and
what that meant but then also there was
an identification
that our food supply chain in the u.s
might be vulnerable and open for attack
so what do we do about it these are very
scary things
but really there's nothing you can do
about it and that
bad actors will be bad actors and all
you can do is mitigate risk
so really the goal of this intentional
adulteration program
was to create a risk mitigation plan
um many of us are have been working on
our food defense plans which need to be
incorporated
into our household plans some sources of
intentional adulteration
include disgruntled employees those
seeking
economic benefits as well as foreign and
domestic extremists seeking public harm
so very little control
over these risks but
all you can do is mitigate it's still a
huge issue
of concern so that's why the usda
fda industry partners as well as the
department of homeland security and the
fda got together
and really tried to decide what can we
do about it
they really thought the program if you
see something say something
was really the best path forward they
have it open on their portal
uh or food safety so you can go into the
portal and if
you are feel that there is a risk that
needs to be reported it is open and
therefore you
and then on the right i just have some
uh this is from
fda guidance and the usda also
uh follows a very similar uh bullets
on how things to think about as you're
creating your food defense plan
just some kind of steps lots of
resources available for you
with usda and fda so i would encourage
you as you're developing your plans
um to kind of look through those as a
resource
so at the end of the day um a lot of
governmental
and global influence on our food
but at the end of the day again it's
about you
and what do you want um so here are some
topics
uh that really have come out this is by
no means an exhaustive
list consumers are very demanding
i know i am so um you know we always
want something new and something
different
so these are some of the top ones that
uh and
industry and consumer groups are really
talking to
so we're going to really touch on these
today so
one is this idea of reduction we want to
lead healthier happier lifestyles
so really going with this sugar and salt
reduction the who has a goal
of reducing salt intake by 30
in just five more years this is a
tremendous amount
however they feel it will save 2.5
million lives a year by being able to
reduce
salt intake some of the recommendations
are to reduce the amount of salt
available
in consumer formulations uh having
less salts available so when you go to
the restaurants
they're recommending not having salt and
pepper at the table
to having that as a ask
or um and then also they are pushing
for additional salt labeling
recommendations
or requirements um
so that's how they're thinking about
salt
now the sugar industry is going a
different
route last week they put forth a
petition to the fda
to revise and review uh labeling
requirements in regards to sugar and
sweeteners
they felt that they were at a
disadvantage in that
many consumer products
make marketing claims in regards to
sugar
and sweetness however there are still
there may not be sugar in the product
there is sweetener our sweeteners in the
product
and they would really prefer and feel
that it is more
transparent to the consumer to allow
them to know
that although it says that um
there isn't it's sugar-free that there
are sweeteners still in that product
and also the levels at which those
sweeteners exist in the product
um they feel this will make it a more
even marketplace across the board
because um whereas sugar does have some
health risks
associated with it uh so do sweetener
alternatives so just leveling that
playing field
um this will be an interesting spot to
watch in the next couple weeks
as the fda responds to the petition so
stay tuned
here um another hot topic switching
industries
is the salmonella petition that was
submitted to the usda
in uh january of this year uh the marler
law firm
submitted a petition requesting that
salmonella be listed as an
adulterant similar to
e coli o 1 5 7 h7 and sugar toxin
producing e coli
it specifically called out 31
sterotypes of salmonella that they
considered based on historical evidence
of illness
the key indicators of
risk and as some background
from the cdc salmonella has the highest
degree of risk in poultry
and of work and is suspect cause
for around 420 deaths per year
so there is some risk associated with
salmonella
um so the or usda um
the food safety investigative services
uh responded that they would take this
under consideration
and they did uh they put it out for
public comments
uh lots of comments over 377
comments were received at the closing on
may 22nd
um and most recently uh the marler
team submitted additional comments and
context
addressing some of the concerns that
were raised in the public comments
such as it would be very
expensive to the industry to employ this
amount of additional testing
one the testing didn't provide
quite the end result employed
as far as it may or may not detect uh
salmonella um in the final product that
there was
always a final kill step for the
pathogen
and then also that
salmonella unlike e coli isn't something
that is an
additive to uh
the poultry or pork or meat product
it um it's always present in the lymph
nodes and therefore
there is less ability to control
it being in the product
so more to come here um the usda
is reviewing comments and is set to put
out
a further response later this year so
definitely another hot spot to keep
watch and finally i'm sorry i have to
make the joke but we're going to end on
a high note
um and talk about cbd hemp and all
things cannabis
there's a lot of misinformation right
now regarding
hemp and cannabis regulations um but
just to set
the very most simplistic records
strange in regards to fdna
fda regulations under the fdnc act
thc and cbd products cannot be sold as
dietary supplements
or as an additive uh for food
for humans or animals and then
ingredients derived from cannabis that
do not contain cbd or thc may be used
if they meet all other fdmc requirements
at present the only
cannabis uh type product
that is approved for food human
food use are hemp c drive
products so whole hemp seed hemp seed
protein power and
powder and hemp seed oil
no other products have been approved for
human use um as required to be gross
generally recognized and safe or
as a new novel dietary ingredient
at present this is the state and stance
of the fda
um from a federal government perspective
this does not include any guidance or
regulations from the states
that is completely separate the other
piece of this
uh as last year the farm bill was passed
which gave usda oversight over the hemp
industry
and also removed hemp as being a
schedule one controlled substance
which opened it up for further use
usda is working very diligently
um creating a guidance and review
on what the industry can expect and see
from him
in the future they had open public
comments which closed in february of
this year
and a meeting i attended earlier this
year actually in february as well
with the usda they explained that
um they would review all of the comments
very thoroughly and put forth the best
practices
learned from the industry um that really
support the industry
and not starting from scratch to really
what are those best practices that make
scientific
sense and move forward with some of them
so
they are anticipating having guns out uh
later in the year
to flourish so um definitely
more updates to come there
so i know we covered so many different
topics
um today and it's a little overwhelming
i'm sure
um but just to kind of touch base um you
know
regulations or being influenced at a
global level
and a personal level so anywhere from
the global food safety initiative
to crazy things that you have no control
over like a
pandemic um but there's also things
happening in the government updates
but at the end of the day it's really
what do you want
and what do you need to make a safe
healthy
food environment for you and your family
so thank you i want to thank you all for
your time today and your attention
i really appreciate us and your
attention and uh being able to have this
discussion today
and thank you jessica for that
presentation
um we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
and reminder to audience if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we have a couple questions from our
audience members
this is which regulation do you think
will have the greatest
impact on our industry
so thank you for the question this is a
really great one
um i really for me the most important
piece
is really what's going on on the um
intentional adulteration there's so many
different groups
um working on this right now as far as
um aoac has a specific working group
thinking about what standards do we need
to have in place
how do we even test for something we
don't know
um the national institute of standards
and testing
nist is also working on what are those
reference materials
that really need to be created uh what
matrices do they need to be in
to make sure that we're really testing
um
and able to have at least a response
plan
and put some science behind what's going
on here
thank you for that we have another
question from our audience what type of
support
does millipore sigma offer for these
regulations
that is another great question um thank
you for that
um so we offer support um
as you've heard in our presentations
earlier this week
um you know we're having increasing need
for environmental monitoring
if you get an opportunity to
replay tim slurs presentation on
environmental monitoring
where he talks about you know how to
implement your household plan to really
identify risks for the pathogens
we have tremendous microbiology support
to really help
identify and support those regulations
as well as if you have an opportunity uh
to replay
matthias knowles presentation on
reference materials
um understanding um the reference
materials play
on for adult intentional adulteration
um just all sorts of elements and then
finally
uh our lenexo offer to really
that using digital tools to simplify
your supply chain
and just really get the right products
and really
that transparency into what's going on
where everything is
and when it is in the process i think
are some of our key large
big ones as well as a whole portfolio
of amazing products that you can find on
our food and beverage
uh portal site on at sigmaaldrich.com
thank you justice and what a great
presentation i know that the audience
can find you
in the middle liverpool stigma lounge
right after our talk and um i want to
encourage them to go there right after
and also to check out
the miliport sigma exhibit hall but do
you have any closing remarks
that you want to provide the audience
before we close today
um just um obviously thank you for your
attendance
but then um just to know um regulations
always seem scary
and um just so overwhelming but
uh really they're just a way to
you make people safer and have a
better path forward and you know it's
not only the regulator's
responsibility to make sure of this it's
our responsibility
so you know any part that we can play
committing best practices
uh really just makes the world a better
safer place
absolutely again thank you for your time
today and for your important research
before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today
for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration thank you again to our
sponsor military sigma
again i encourage you to go check out
the lounge and
the exhibit hall um this webcast can be
reviewed on demand
through june of 2021. until next time
everyone
best practices take care and be safe bye